should have kept the mac I told you as  important  Wilner far way what sort of what every  contraction excuse me are you sure it's  gonna work I go ah thank you sir it's  rather dark down here is a small year we  have to find market for ya we're going  through the forest burst is there any  other way we could get to the mountain  without going through Mirkwood  we take this iron horse to Mirkwood  forest will this lead us to murder would  excuse me do you know how to get to  Lonely Mountain Earth taking it man  nobody knows where anything is here  we're completely lost where are we we've  been underground for too long I think it  wants us to push it don't do it  the dwarfs split you there that way we  still could go home actually  what are we stole in the costume thank  you  thank you thank you thank you so much  yeah  one day